la connaissance intuitive une science
oublié par les hommes telle est notre
sujet de présentation le vedanta 1
textes sacrés hindous professe que le
cycle humain que l'histoire de
intellectuelle de l'humanité par des
passe par des étapes
il reconnaît quatre étapes ou quatre
grands âges
le yoga ce sathya le traité yoga le
débarras yoga et le kali yuga ch
correspondrait à une dégénérescence
progressive de l'âme humaine ou du
raisonnement humain de la spirituelle du
temps spirituels en passe
progressivement vers le temps matériel
dans le temps de la matière de la
multiplicité à l'infini des conflits des
guerres le dernier âge étant le call you
go ou la spiritueux spiritualité
primordial où l'âme de la spiritualité
ce occultes et disparaît et la c1 tente
de violence est reine de chaos où la
sagesse la connaissance divine ma
connaissance vraie devient inaccessible
ce temps correspondrait ou correspond
avec ce qu'on appelle de la tradition
musulmane
avoir deux semaines aux mêmes sources
règle colonie grandit ensuite il y aura
un âge qui viendra après pourquoi quand
même en ag le meilleur c'est l'âge de la
spiritualité de l'âme dans l'oreillette
viendra un temps après où cette
connaissance divine
cette connaissance de l'intuition de qui
se ressent il viendra dans quelques
secondes des aurait disparu ou très peu
en seraient les dépositaires
qu'est ce qu'une science intuitive avant
on parle de disparition de quelque chose
du sagesse universelle
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
sagesse que cette science du verbe latin
regardez au tueur le terme intuition
renvoie vers le regard intérieur ce
qu'on appelle dans la tradition
musulmane elle passera au sens où en
plus de l'oeil extérieur qui nous permet
de voir les choses de les distinguer
tout homme du simple fait qu'ils soient
hommes disposent de cette vision
intérieure de cet oeil à l'intérieur qui
lui permet de regarder les vérités
céleste les vérités
chez la mala temps défini cette
intuition
c'est la saisie midi la saisie immédiate
de la vérité de l'idée par l'âme
indépendamment du corps c'est à dire que
cet intérieur saisi les vérités des
idées les vérités sens des choses quand
le plan matériel dolomites hermes
métaphysique les vérités ou le monde
nous sommes un interniste brothers entre
demande le monde de la matière et le
monde des idées le monde moult et le
mâle écoute pas là tandis que cette
exhibition ce monde des idées ne peut
être saisi que par cette intuition
intellectuelle que chacun d'entre nous
est gratifié l existence chacun l'a 28
soit intellectuel qu est ce que c est ce
la raison
ou est ce un niveau supérieur à la
raison là selon le raset lit le
philosophe musulman montremy 111 l'homme
passerait par cinq niveaux d'évolution
de ces négligences
depuis sa venue au monde 1 re es el raay
ali est la relie à vos fils fikri où il
commence à méditer où il pense où il
arrive à des déductions
mais la plupart des hommes s'arrêtent
ici on ne peut dépasser ce stade on est
prisonniers de notre raison comme hymne
à la bêtise et la clouait lahlimi lady
lay intérêts elmo world gèrent-ils où la
ville est intelligent on est en même
temps prisonniers de nos idées de notre
intellect en nous gardent prisonnier là
il ya un cinquième niveau c'est la
faculté saint-andré fraude aussi là il
permet de sortir de la presse relate de
la prison de la matière car le champ
d'investigation de la raison
la raison travail sur la matière sur les
objets sur tout ce qui est visible
elle rassemble nos sens nous apporte une
quantité infinie d'information les yeux
la vue l'ouïe l'odorat et quelques
affaires la raison elle va les analyser
et déduire
mais là il ya un autre niveau de
perception qui auront elles aussi que
chacun peut atteindre et il existe en
chacun est là mais très peu d'entre
d'entre nous y parviennent et le
développe là et
le problème qu'en est-il de l'intuition
intellectuelle dans la tradition
musulmane
comme pour les autres traditions l'islam
reconnaît qu'il y a deux ordres de
sciences deux ans de connaissances
cette connaissance matériel cette
connaissance acquise qu'on peut
apprendre et il ya eu notre connaissance
c'est la connaissance divine on c'est
une intuition c'est quoi une institution
comme disait pelatan qui est capté par
l'âme qui vient d'en haut et non de la
matière là elle est différemment appelé
parfois on la trouve sous le nom de al
masdar hier matin ll moi il m a dit tu
es le monde dayron et edmond batignole
une science cacher parfois elle est
appelée science acquises et sur
s'octroyer elie métallos wayne rooney ou
rouge
ils menaient dolly qui est donnée par le
divin il vient d'en haut c'est une
sagesse et parfois la science de la
raison et la science du coeur animal ou
un email
c'est l'oeil intérieur qui voit ses
sciences qui les captent et là il ya un
exemple assez illustratif qui nous est
donnée par le coran qui est le récit de
la grande rencontre entre un prophète
qui avaient toutes les sciences de son
temps et heure à dire qui était un saint
il lui pose la question
le dieu lui dit il ya 1,5 ya une science
que tu n'as pas il va le voir et le
coran dit elle tenait à vous miled ou la
lma a sera dire on a donné à ce saint
est à dire on a octroyé les dolines
elmaleh doni cette science et moïse va
le vent lui apprends moi cette science
que tu as à lima lim au choix que fera
bien il initie à cette science mais
d'une manière subtile
c'est une science elle mènera pire
layton il oublie sa patience intuitive
le peuple n'est pas rédigé elle pas elle
ne peut pas transmise le lie à millwall
lisait la parole ne peut la contenir
comment il va l'initier il ici à cette
science subtilement il trouve un bateau
des gens qui les aident
il détruit le bateau qu'est ce que tu as
fais là tu as détruit un bateau de son
port ensuite il lui dit non
cette intuition m'avait montré que se
battait bateau allait être saisie est
pris par un roi gelé détruit là il était
dans un autre ordre à délaver une
science qui lui permettait ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui de voir le futur il
a vu ce qui allait se passer par cette
perception intellectuelle ça ce récit
est vraiment à méditer il ya beaucoup
d'autres exemples de connaissances
intuitives
là elle rappelle à vue le futur c'est
tel enseignement pour nous parce qu il
yad autres sciences intuitive la science
des rêves comment pourquoi il ya des
gens qui ont des rêves et qui voit des
phénomènes et ça arrive d'autres n'ont
pas et en même temps ça certains savent
interpréter les rêves d'autres ne sont
pas les interpréter ceux qui savent
interpréter l'herbe on les appelle nous
fait si elle aime tout ce qu'ils ont
trouvé cette science est ce qu'il ya des
ouvrages et non pas des ouvrages vous
lui dites j'ai rêvé d'un avion il vous
l'interprète de 7 et ça se réalise
pourquoi ça s'est réalisé pour certains
et pas pour d'autres
la grande question qui est posée
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont cette science
justement c'est un dedans et il ya le
l'exemple qui est donné celui du
prophète joseph a été interdite là ils
appliquent ma une science qui lui a été
donnée d'interpréter les rêves
il ya beaucoup d'autres saints qui ont
eu cette science comme hebdo sedin qui
est connu dans notre tradition comme
étant le grand interprète des rêves et
là il ya le rêve son interpétation
change d'une personne à une autre
une personne vient voir et de céline lui
dit j'ai vu que j'appelais à la prière
il lui dit à main va être coupée un
autre vient lui dit et lui raconte le
même rêve il lui dit non tu vas aller au
pèlerinage plus quelques temps après une
pose la question est comment vous avez
su il a su tout simplement comment il
l'a ressenti c'est une science qui lui a
été octroyé ils eurent explique après
parce que le premier j'ai vu que c'était
pas un an pieux en disant j'ai vu laden
ça voulait dire par là des mots a dit
nyan win a comme la salle ayroles à
servir c'est l'amputation pour le
deuxième j'ai vu
qu'il était pieux qu'il était un homme
de bonne famille elie le verset qui me
vient à l'esprit c'est dépenser qui
viennent c'est pas lui qui les a le
verset qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
delphine dans ces villages
là c'est la science des rêves et ses
vastes il yad'autres science la science
du symbolisme divin comment interpréter
les symboles de dieu le monde qui nous
entoure
comment la tradition d'appel et y est
il existe deux livres le livre sacré la
haine et oracle inutiles tous les autres
livres
il existe elle la whey el man show c'est
le livre de l'existence d'un grand singe
cheikh el alaoui 10 et les taximen alpha
et bêta il n'est malraux allophones
watteau l'os c'est personne ses formes
que vous voyez sont des lettres et des
formes mais qui d'entre nous peut les
interpréter
c'est aussi une science octroyer ce qui
en cette science peuvent comprendre le
symbolisme des choses qui nous entourent
une autre science c'est la science des
lettres la science des lettres c est les
flaming kefaya un sac à main on dit que
c'est selon certains des formules
mathématiques qui contiendrait tout le
secret de l'univers tout ce qui s'est
passé et tout ce qui arrivera
mais cris peu les percées c'est en corse
est une science po octroyé qui est
donnée à qui dieu le veut un autre
exemple
et je terminerai par cet exemple c'est
celui ce qu'on appelle de la fira ça qui
est une science octroyé le prophétisé
iter conférence est les mobiles
verrouillant bobino il est prenez gare à
l'intuition offert à sa du croyant car
il regarde pas la lumière de dieu
et là il ya des personnes qui ont le
temps de comprendre le caractère des
gens vous mentez il comprend que vous
avez monde